[Music] I'd some snacks yeah yeah I was gonna say a peanutbutter M&M and nachos because that's what I like my character loves not just the Johnny Hyde snacks no that's true don't divide a snack go back five to forty bill default before and peyote food I think I think anything with a lot of calcium I mean I get a big big tub of popcorn I say right in the middle I like middle slightly front center right whatever the most boring thing is in a very orderly fashion I think I'd be like loitering in the doorway like it's like a weirdo that just like doesn't commit to sitting down TalkTalk you guys have those cream with frozen chocolate on top that classic in Australia [Music]